MORE MEMBERS SO WILL HAVE A
QUORUM.
NOW WE HAVE A QUORUM.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A QUORUM --
SO WE CAN START --
LET ME JUST STAFF.
IN ORDER IS BACK.
ALL RIGHT SIR WELCOME TO OUR
FIRST LEGISLATIVE HEARING.
OF THE ASSEMBLY ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY AND TOXIC MATERIALS
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR --
BEFORE WE START I WANT TO
MENTION MELISSA MELENDEZ OF VICE
CHAIR IS OUT TODAY AND JOAQUIN
ARAMBULA IS ALSO OUT TODAY --
WE WILL STILL EVEN THOUGH --
WILL HAVE A ONLY SEVEN OF US
HERE IT STILL REQUIRES FIVE
VOTES. TO TO PASS ANYTHING OUT
SO EVEN THOUGH THERE'S ONLY
SEVEN OF US IT'S STILL IS GOING
TO REQUIRE FIVE VOTES.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME BACK --
MY ONE OF MY FAVORITE PEOPLE
BRIAN DOLLY.
OUR WHO WILL SERVE.
AS THE VICE CHAIR.
WHEN?
OR OR WILL CHAIR THE MEETING
WHEN I HAVE TO PRESENT MY TWO
BILLS -- THE
T. END.
UP MY GOOD FRIEND --
REBEKAH BAUER KAHAN IS ALSO A
NEW MEMBER.
AND YEAH I'VE ACTUALLY WILL
PROBABLY HAVE A DEVON MATHIS
SHOW UP ANOTHER NEW MEMBER WHO
WAS A SUBSTITUTE LAST YEAR IN
SHOWS SUCH GREAT INTEREST.
THAT I WAS VERY GLAD. TO HAVE
HIM APPOINTED BY THE SPEAKER TO
BE ON THE COMMITTEE AS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH.
THE MINORITY LEADER. TO HAVE HIM
ON THE THOUGHTFUL AS IS.
AS ARE ALL OF THE MEMBERS HERE.
ARM.
SO WE HEARING FIVE BUILT SO --
WHY DON'T YOU --
TAKE THE ROLE AND WILL OF
CHALLENGE QUORUM.
QUIRK.
QUIRK IS HERE.
MELENDEZ IS ABSENT -ARAMBULA AS
ABSENT.
BAUER-KAHAN HERE BAUER-KAHAN
HERE DALY.
DALY IS HERE CRISTINA GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA IS HERE.
HOLDEN HOLDEN IS HERE.
MATHIS.
WHAT A TO CHANGE THAT'S WHAT
SHE'S HERE SO WE HAVE A QUORUM?
ALL RIGHT ARE THERE FIVE BILLS
TWO OF WHICH ARE ON CONSENT
[inaudible]
AND TESTIMONIAL BE LIMITED TO
FOUR MINUTES PER SIDE SO THE
MEETING SHOULD GO FAIRLY QUICKLY.
THE TWO BILLS ON CAN SANDER ITEM
NUMBER TWO A. B. TWO NINETY TWO
QUIRK.
AND AT ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B.
THREE TWENTY QUIRK.
SO THAT'S A MOVE IN THE SECOND
FOR BOTH.
ALL RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FOR CONSENT CALENDAR --
AB TWO NINETY TWO QUIRK AND AB
[inaudible]
THREE TWENTY QUIRK.
THE MOTION FOR A BI TO NINETY
TWO IS DUE PASSING RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON WATER PARKS AND
WILDLIFE WITH THE RECOMMENDATION
OF CONSENT.
AND AB THREE TWENTY TO PASS AN
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATION OF CONSENT
[inaudible]
QUIRK.
HI QUIRK HI.
MELENDEZ IS ABSENT AUDIBLE AS
ABSENT [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DALY.
DALY I CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE AYE.
MATHIS.
WHAT TO CHANGE WHEN I TO GI SO
WE DO HAVE ENOUGH VOTES TO PASS
ALL RIGHT IN SESSION WE HAVE?
SIX VOTES AND THE NEXT ITEM WILL
BE ASSEMBLY MEMBER CRISTINA
GARCIA.
AND SHE WILL BE.
AB -- ONE
FORTY TWO AND IT WITH A I FORGOT
BUT JUST TO HAVE A SEAT.
I WANT TO CONGRATULATE DEVON
MATHIS ON HIS APPOINTMENT TO THE
COMMITTEE --
HE WAS -- AS
HE SAID A VERY INTERESTED
THOUGHTFUL PERSON WHEN HE
SUBSTITUTED LAST YEAR AND I I
WAS HOPING WE WOULD GET HIM ON
AND HE IS AND I'M I'M VERY GLAD
TO HAVE YOU ALL --
WE DO WANT.
TO WHEN IT YOU JUST WITH PASSED
THE CONSENT CALENDAR DO YOU WANT
TO VOTE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I GET ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE OKAY --
AND THEN WE HAVE THE RULES TO
ADOPT --
DOES THE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS ON
THE RULES.
OKAY THAT BEING SAID --
MAKE A MOTION TO ADOPT.
GOOD --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS THE ADOPTION OF THE
COMMITTEE RULES --
DIAGO AHEAD ONE MOMENT.
SHARE.
AND ONE OTHER FREE DENTAL CARE
DOES NOT HAVE TO HEAR BILL.
YOU KNOW I SO I I DO NOT KNOW IF
THAT'S IN THE RULES IS IT IN OUR
RULES.
IT'S IN THE HOUSE RULES I INTEND
TO HEAR EVERY DETAIL
[inaudible]
THAT'S MY WE DON'T HAVE THE
PRESENT THE BILL.
WELL IT'S BUT IT'S NOT IN OUR
ROLES.
THAT.
OUR ROLES --
BUT IT'S IN THE HOUSE RULES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WHATEVER I'M VOTE ON THE RULES
CAN GO FORWARD THEN AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR CONCERN.
SOME PEOPLE THAT YOU DON'T WANT
TO HEAR FROM AND I DON'T THINK
THAT'S I DON'T THINK IT WOULD BE
FAIR.
YEAH ALL RIGHT WELL WE'LL JUST
VOTE ON THE ROLES AND YOU'LL DO
WHAT YOU'RE GONNA DO --
CELL MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ON A VOTE TO ADOPT OUR
COMMITTEE ROLES ARE QUIRK.
YES OUR AYE.
MELENDEZ IS ABSENT AUTUMN LESS
ABSENT.
BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN HI DELI.
DELI NO CRISTINA GARCIA HI
CRISTINA GARCIA I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I NO.
WHAT I TO CHEAT MODE SWITCHING I?
THREE FOUR FIVE SO WE HAVE FIVE
WE HAVE FIVE VOTES AND I AM I ET --
RESPECT VERY MUCH YOUR POSITION
IT WHAT'S IN A ROLE THAT I
PARTICULARLY CARE FOR EITHER.
ARM.
ALL RIGHT NOW WE'LL GET ON TO A
VERY IMPORTANT --
PC BUSINESS.
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS --
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE
PASSED AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE
AND WHICH WAS SIGNED INTO LAW.
WHICH REALLOCATED A FEE ALREADY
IMPOSED ON ALL CAR BATTERIES TO
FUND THE CLEANUP OF
CONTAMINATION COSTS BY LEAD ACID
BATTERIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I IN RESPONSE TO THE MAN MADE
DISASTER EXCITING IN MY BACKYARD.
WE'RE HERE TODAY WITH AB ONE
FORTY TWO WHICH ADDRESSES THREE
TECHNICAL PROBLEMS THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN THE FERMENTATION.
OF THIS FUND.
STATE MANY FACTORS CAN TO PAY A
ONE DOLLAR FEE ON ALL BATTERY
SOLD IN THE STATE.
THE BILL WILL ALSO ALLOW THE CD
TFA TO POST WHO IS REGISTERED
WITH THE REGISTER MANUFACTURE ON
THEIR WEBSITE.
THIS IS SIMILAR TO OTHER FEE
PROGRAMS THAT THEY ADMINISTER.
IT ALSO CLARIFIES THAT THE
CONSUMER FEAST ON NOT APPLY TO
ANY PERSON WHEN THE REPLACEMENT
LEAD BACK AT THE BATTERY IS
INCLUDED IN ANY USED VEHICLE
SOLD OR LEASED.
BY A NEW MOTOR VEHICLE DEALER.
UNDER CURRENT LAW AT THE POINT
OF SALE ONE DOLLAR FOR THE
CONSUMERS THE AYE IS DEPOSITED.
ODD TO THE CLEAN UP FIND MANY
FACTORS ALSO PAY A ONE DOLLAR
FEE ON ALL BATTERY SOLD IN THE
STATE. THIRTY APRIL FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE CONSUMER FEEL
INCREASE TO TWO DOLLARS AND THE
MANUFACTURE OF FEE WILL SUNSET.
THE SENSITIVITY WAS TAKEN ON THE
LAST THEIR SESSION AS A
REQUIREMENT THAT THE GOVERNOR
ASKED US FOR NO ONE WANTED THE
TO SUNSET NOT MYSELF NOT THE
INDUSTRY NOT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS.
WE GOVERNOR WANTED.
THIS WILL THEN BE RACES THE
MANUFACTURE FEE TO TWO DOLLARS
WELL TO KEEP THE FUN EQUITABLE.
THE FINAL FACILITY CLEAN UP
REPRESENT OF EXCITEMENT OTHER
SIMILAR SITES TO REMEDIATION
WILL BE THE DELAYED BASED ON AN
INABILITY TO GET FUNDING FOR THE%
COMPANIES THAT CREATED THE
SITUATION IN THE FIRST PLACE.
OR RELY ON THE GENERAL FUND.
THIS ONE HAS BEEN BRINGING
RELIEF TO THOSE AFFECTED
COMMUNITIES AND ENSURE SOLUTIONS
TO MAJOR LONG TERM PROBLEMS.
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THE FINE HAS RAISED
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
FORTUNATELY THE CLEANUP WHICH AS
THESE HOMES AROUND THE NECK
SITES IS ESTIMATED TO BE.
BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION AND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS.
WE DON'T INCREASE THE
MANUFACTURE FEEL TAKE OVER
THIRTY YEARS TO FUND THE CLEANUP
AND THAT'S SIMPLY NOT ACCEPTABLE.
LASTLY THIS BILL AT A PROVISION
THAT THE CHEN CAN ONLY BE REPAID
WANTS TO CLEAN UP THE SON OF
EXCITED AND THE THIRTEEN OTHER
HISTORIC BATTERY MANUFACTURING
FACILITIES.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY HAVE DEAN
WILLIAM WITH CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES AGAINST TOXICS AND
BRIAN STAGGER WITH THE LA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS --
JANE WILLIAMS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
AGAINST TOXIC SUNNY ALSO CHAIR
THE TECHNICAL --
GROUP FOR THE EXCITE COMMITTED
BY REGROUP --
THERE'S ABOUT FIFTEEN OF THESE
GO SMELTERS IN CALIFORNIA --
WE ARE HOPING THAT.
NONE OF THEM ARE THE MAGNITUDE
OF CONTAMINATION FROM THE X. I.
FACILITY BUT THEY'RE ALL GONNA
NEED TO BE CLEANED UP AND HERE'S
WHY -- A
VERY EXTENSIVE STUDY THAT WE DID
IN CALIFORNIA --
AROUND THE EXITE FACILITY
LOOKING AT LEAD POISONING BY THE
CENSUS TRACT.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY ABOUT ONE
POINT 92% OF KIDS HAVE LED ABOVE
FIVE MICROGRAMS PROJECT LEADER.
BUT IN A NUMBER OF THE CENSUS
TRACKS AROUND EXCITED THAT.
CAN RISE TO UP 25%.
AND THOSE OF US ON THE EXCITED
CAG --
REALIZE SAID ABOUT EVERY DAY
SEPARATELY IN THE COMMUNITIES
SURROUNDING THE EXITE FACILITY.
AND WE EXPECT THAT TO BE
OCCURRING AT A NUMBER OF THESE
OTHER SMELTERS AND THAT WAS WHY
IT WAS VERY IMPORTANT TO US TO
INITIATE AND PASS THE BATTERY
FEE SO THAT WE CAN START
INVESTIGATING.
THE SLIGHT SWELL CONTAMINATION
PROBLEM ACROSS THE STATE.
AND WE CERTAINLY HOPE WITH NEW
LEADERSHIP KELLY PA WE CAN
ACCELERATE THOSE EFFORTS AND WE
HAD AN OVERSIGHT HEARING --
LAST FALL --
AND MANY MEMBERS OF THE EXCITED
CAG CAME AND TESTIFIED AND SO
THERE'S A LOT OF ATTENTION ON
EXCITED BUT WE NEED ATTENTION ON
THESE OTHER COMMUNITIES.
TO TORRANCE WEST OAKLAND THERE'S
A A FORMER SMELTER HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
THERE'S ONE IN FRESNO --
THERE'S A NUMBER IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
SO -- YES --
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AT
THE TIME IF THEY WOULD PLEASE.
GET A C. STABLE SOURCE OF
FUNDING OVER TIME SO THAT WE CAN
APPROACH THIS WE REVIEW THE
FIRST STATE IN THE COUNTRY. TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE.
A EFFORT TO REDUCE LEAD SOUL
CONTAMINATION IN HIGHLY IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES AND THE GIRL THAT
HOST THE OLD GHOST MELCHER'S.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE BRAINS ON THE
HALF OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE ARE HERE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SUNDAY BUT
ONE FORTY TWO AND WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP.
IN THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE --
AS MISS WILLIAMS SAID YOU KNOW
THE EXCITED.
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT.
THE CONTAMINATION COULD AFFECT
THE HEALTH OF OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND COUNTY RESIDENTS --
AND THAT'S A HUGE ISSUE OF FOR
COUNTY WE CERTAINLY REALIZE THAT
THE PASSAGE OF AB ONE FORTY TWO
WILL PROVIDE A FUNDING STREAM
THAT WILL.
HELP IN THE CLEANUP EFFORTS WE
THINK THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY --
ENVIRONMENT WORKING GROUP IN
SUPPORT AND GET A LETTER IN TIME --
A LITTLE BIT THAT IS OKAY I
WANTED TO READ THE ANALYSIS
WHICH I WANT TO COMPLIMENT YOUR
STAFF ON IS VERY THOROUGH I READ
THE OPPONENT'S ARGUMENT.
TO SEE IF THEY THINK IT'S
PREMATURE WE DONE ESPECIALLY
WITH JANE WILLIAMS.
CAME IN ORGANIZATIONAL COVER
THAT LATER THE WG IN SUPPORT
THANKS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RISK OF CASA
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE PAUL GUNS ALL THIS
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE FOUR MINUTES DIVIDED
HOWEVER YOU'D LIKE IT.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
JEFF SIGNATURE WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE BATTERY
COUNCIL INTERNATIONAL --
WANT TO START BY RECOGNIZING THE
FACT THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS
HERE REACHED OUT TO US.
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY UPON
INTRODUCTION OF THE BILL AND WE
BEEN ENGAGED IN.
WHAT WE HOPE WILL CONTINUE TO BE
A COLLABORATIVE CONVERSATION?
ABOUT TELL WHERE THE FEE
COMPONENT OF AB ONE FORTY TWO IS
HEADED.
AND I WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THAT THAT THERE ARE
ASPECTS OF THE BILL THAT WE VERY
MUCH SUPPORT CERTAINLY.
THE LANGUAGE IT CLARIFIES THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF A OF FEE
PAYERS AND REGISTRATION
REQUIREMENTS.
OUR HOPE IS THAT THAT WILL LEAD
TO ADDITIONAL REVENUE FLOW EVEN
WITHIN THE EXISTING FEE
STRUCTURE THAT UNTAPPED
POTENTIAL THAT I THINK WE'RE ALL.
TRYING TO CAPTURE HERE --
AND WE ALSO SUPPORT.
THE EMPHASIS IN THE BILL ON
DIRECTING THE REVENUE TO ACTUAL
SITE CLEANUP WHICH WAS.
THE SHARED.
INTENT OF ALL THE PARTIES WHO
NEGOTIATED.
TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE OUR
PRIMARY CONCERN --
IS MOVING AHEAD WITH THE FEE
INCREASE.
AS WE ARE RECEIVING ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM CITY TFA AND%
DTS SEE WHICH WILL HELP.
DEFINE OF WHAT THE REVENUE
BALLOTS WILL NEED TO BE GOING
FORWARD. TO ADDRESS NOT ONLY THE
EXISTING PROBLEMS BUT THE ONES
THAT MISS WILLIAMS ALLUDED TO
THE DTS HE IS.
STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
INVESTIGATING.
AND UP AT THE MOMENT WE KNOW
THAT CITY TFA IS IS TRYING TO
DEFINE THE REVENUE POTENTIAL
UNDER THE EXISTING FEE STRUCTURE.
AND IT'S NOT JUST A CONCERN
ABOUT THE DISCREPANCY THAT THE
ANALYSIS ALLUDES TO BETWEEN WHAT.
REVENUE IS BEING COLLECTED FROM
THE MANUFACTURER ACTED.
FROM OTHER RETAIL FEE.
IT'S THERE ARE OTHER ANOMALIES
THAT WERE TRYING.
TO UNDERSTAND AND DEFINE --
THERE'S ABOUT A TWO AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLAR GAP BETWEEN --
CITY TFA IS REVENUE NUMBERS AND
THE PROJECTIONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
AS I ALLUDED TO A MINUTE AGO
IT'S NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR AT THIS
POINT THAT EVERYONE THAT HAS A
COMPLIANCE OBLIGATION IS
REGISTERED.
AND THAT EVERY REGISTRANT THAT
HAS A FEE OBLIGATION IS
COLLECTING AND REMITTING THOSE
FUNDS TO THE STATE --
MAN AGAIN I'M I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE WE SHARE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS DESIRE TO NOT TO LEAVE
ANY OF THAT MONEY ON THE TABLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT.
IT IS INVESTED --
FOR FOR THE RIGHT PURPOSES --
AND I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE?
WHAT AMOUNT OF MONEY THE
DEPARTMENT CAN REASONABLY SPEND
IN A GIVEN FISCAL CYCLE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS WERE EXPECTING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM DTS
SEE?
WHETHER WILL HELP ADDRESS SAYS
ONLY ABOUT A MINUTE LEFT YOU
WANT THE OTHER TEACHER WHO TO
SPEAK LET LET ME JUST.
JUMP TO THE BOTTOM LINE THEN --
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE FEE
INCREASE BUT WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FEE BECOMING
A MOVING TARGET OVER TIME.
SO WE WANT TO INFORM.
THE WITH THE BEST POSSIBLE
INFORMATION BEFORE WE MOVED FROM.
HI YEAH I'LL BE REAL QUICK --
PERSONAL THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TODAY.
MY NAME IS TERRY CAM ONE FROM U.
S. BATTERY MANUFACTURING IN
CORONA CALIFORNIA.
WELL ONE OF THE FIVE BATTERY
MANUFACTURERS LEFT IN CALIFORNIA.
AND WHILE WE ATE WE STRONGLY.
SUPPORT MUCH OF WHAT CHRISTINE
IS TRYING TO DO I I I I THINK
IT'S ADMIRABLE --
OBVIOUSLY LEAD IS IS A CHEMICAL
THAT IS HIGHLY TOXIC AND HAS TO
BE CONTROLLED PROPERLY --
WHAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE AS AN
ORGAN IS AS A AS A COMPANY?
IS WE DON'T NECESSARILY MIND THE
FEE BUT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
IT'S GOING TO THE RIGHT
PROVISIONS WE DON'T WANT TO
CLEAN UP EVERYBODY'S EVERYTHING.
RIGHT WE WANNA LIMITED TO JUST
THE BATTERY MANUFACTURERS --
OUR BATTERY SIZE THE GHOST
SOCIETY YOU'D MENTION AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
A LEGACY SITES.
WE DO NOT WANT ANY BATTERY
MANUFACTURER AT INCLUDING
OURSELVES IF THAT THAT WOULD BE
THE CASE AND I AM HIGHLY
DOUBTFUL IT WOULD BE --
THAT WOULD AID --
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO CLICK
WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO PAY. TO
CLEAN UP FOR THEIR MISTAKES.
WE DON'T THINK IT THIS FAIRS IN
INDUSTRY A AND AND QUITE FRANKLY
IT'S IT'S QUITE A FISCAL BURDEN
OUR OUR OUR COMPANY ALONE.
AND AS WE MOVE FOR TRYING TO
GENERATE NEW POSSIBILITIES WITH
BATTERIES WITH NEW WILL
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND ALL OF
THESE OTHER THINGS.
IT MAKES IT DIFFICULT FOR US TO
DO THAT IF WE'RE HAVING TO GIVE
A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY TO PROJECTS
THAT WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE --
ARE YOU KNOW UNNECESSARILY --
SHOULD BE GRANTED THOSE FEES SO
OKAY I UNDERSTAND AND I GAVE YOU
AN EXTRA MINUTE THANK CENTER --
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION --
MEMBERS LIVE IN ALL TOMORROW
BEHALF CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION WE JUST WOULD LIKE
TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH MY
COLLEAGUE THAT REPRESENTS THE
BATTERY BATTERY COUNCIL
INTERNATIONAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SO I BET THE AUTHOR CAN TELL US.
ABOUT YOUR CONCERNS IN TERMS OF
HOW THE FUNDS ARE USED
[inaudible]
AND A ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA GO
AHEAD.
ACTUALLY I'D LIKE TO START OFF
BY SAYING THAT WE HAVE A LOT IN
COMMON IN OUR GOALS AND WE HAVE
BEEN IN COMMUNICATIONS AND
WORKING AND THOSE AT THE IN A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
PREVIOUSLY AND SO AND YOU WANT
TO GIVE CREDIT TO THAT OUR SON
ON THIS ISSUE.
AS WELL THANK YOU --
WE HAVE THE SAME I DON'T THESE
ARE TWO THIRDS WILL BILLS THE
BIG LIVES I DON'T WANT TO KEEP
COMING BACK HERE --
EITHER SO THE MOVIE MP ISSUE IS
SOMETHING THAT I HAVE DATA WERE
OUT THERE WORKING WITH THE
TRYING TO GET THE DATA BECAUSE
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE BEING THE
SMARTEST ABOUT THIS BUT THAT
WERE ABLE TO CLEAN THINGS UP IN
A TIMELY MATTER --
AND SO WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S AT THE EQUITABLE.
BETWEEN THE CONSUMER AND THE
MANY FACTORS OUT THERE ARE IN
THE SAME THING RIGHT WE WE DON'T
WANT CURRENT FOLKS TO THEN SAY
WELL I'M GOING TO MAKE SOMEONE
ELSE.
FROM MY PROBLEMS AND WE WANT TO
HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE ON INTO
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THESE
LEGACY SITES I THINK WE HAVE A
LOT IN COMMON.
OUT THERE --
BUT THE REALITY IS THAT THE FUND
DOLLARS AREN'T COMING IN AT THE
RATE AT WHICH WE NEED THEM TO
THE WILL TO CLEAN UP ACT THAT
ALONE MUCH LESS THE FOURTEEN
OTHER SITES THAT ARE OUT THERE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
I HAVE -- I
HAVE A LOT OF A LOT OF GOOD
FAITH THAT WE'RE GONNA GET TO A
GOOD SOLUTION AND AND WE'RE
GONNA KEEP WORKING TOGETHER.
VERY GOOD --
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
[inaudible]
MISTER DALI.
THANK YOU FIRST OFF TO THE
AUTHOR --
BEEN IN THIS FIGHT WITH YOU FOR
A LONG TIME NOW.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR PASSION
ABOUT IT I'M VERY MUCH AS YOU
RECALL WHEN WE FIRST STARTED OUT
ON THIS MISSION --
TO HELP THE AFFECTS OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO YOUR COMMUNITY --
I SAID WITH YOU THERE BUT I'M
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT --
FIRST OF ALL THE ORAL OR IN THE
PROCESS WE WE WE WE HAVE
COLLECTION AND WE WERE ON THE
GROUND IN YOUR COMMUNITY WHAT IS
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW CAN YOU TELL
ME THAT WITH WHAT THE CURRENT
LEGISLATION THAT WE ACTUALLY
PASSED.
AS FAR AS CLEANING GOES --
THE ADDRESS THAT MAYBE.
IT'S IT'S ESTIMATED THAT IN
TWENTY NINETEEN AND TWENTY
TWENTY EACH YEAR WE'RE GONNA BE
CLEAN UP ABOUT THIRTEEN HUNDRED
HOMES A TOTAL OF TWENTY SIX
HUNDRED HOMES.
THAT THE RATE AT WHICH YOU KNOW
THEY'RE WORKING AT WE WE HAVE UP
TO TEN THOUSAND HOMES THAT NEED
TO BE CLEANED UP AT THAT RATE --
AND SO FOR THAT ALONE WE NEED
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
FOR FOR THE NEXT TWO YEARS A
FUNDING.
ARE WE IT WE HAVE PROVISIONS IN
HERE THAT THE MONEY NEEDS TO BE
USED FOR THIS AND NOT TO FILL
BACK HOLES WITH DTS T. OR WITH
HIGHER FEES ARE ALL THESE OTHER
PLACES RIGHT AND SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE.
THAT IT'S GOING TO WHERE IT'S
SUPPOSED TO MY COMMUNITY SUBSET
THEY WERE VERY VOCAL AT THAT
HEARING IN MY DISTRICT THAT THE
MONEY SHOULD BE USED FOR ITS
INTENTION.
OF THE LACK OF TRUST WITH THE
MONEY BILLION MOVING AROUND.
AND SO MY COMMITMENT IS NOT
JUSTICE TO CLEAN UP THIS MESS
WITH TO MAKE SURE WE DO WHAT WE
SAID OR GONNA DO FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
AND THAT I'M NOT CREATING YOU
KNOW MONEY FOR PET PROJECTS ALL
OVER THE STATE --
AND SO BUT THE REALITY IS IS
THAT WE NEED WE NEED THIS MONEY
AND AND WE NEED AT A AT A FASTER
RATE AT AT WHICH IS COMING IN.
SO MY FOLLOW UP TO THAT IS.
I WAS ASSUMING A LOT OF THAT WAS
HAPPEN IN A WE'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS SINCE THEN AND I
KNOW YOUR FRUSTRATION THERE --
AND YOU KNOW AS YOU RECALL WHEN
WE STARTED OUT THAT YOU KNOW I
WAS VERY CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE POLLUTERS WHO ARE GETTING
OFF THE HOOK BASICALLY SO THE
WAY I LOOK AT THIS IS THAT.
THEY DID THE DAMAGE AND THERE'S
A LOT OF WRONG THINGS IN THAT
COMMUNITY ALONG WITH.
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS AND YOU
NAME IT WITH --
AIR QUALITY IN.
THERE THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN THEY
WERE HONOR A CONTINUING PERMIT
FOR A LONG TIME WHICH I THINK IS
WAS VERY WRONG TO THE PUBLIC IN
AND THERE WAS SOMETHING NOT
RIGHT THERE FOR MANY MANY MANY
YEARS.
BUT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH REALITY
IN REALITY IS THERE'S
CONTAMINATION IN YOUR AREA SO I
WAS OKAY WITH THAT BUT NOW WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THESE HOST SITES
IN.
AND OTHER SITES OUT THERE I
WANNA I WANNA ASK HIM.
WHERE THE RESPONSIBLE PARTIES IN
THIS PROCESS I MEAN?
AT SOME POINT THAT THE THE OR
THE TAX AND MIKE IT'S IT'S ADDED
ON TO STE TO SOMEBODY WHO DIDN'T
CAUSE THE PROBLEM.
AND THE PEOPLE BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM GET TO WALK.
AND I THINK THAT'S NOT FAIR TO
THE REST OF CALIFORNIA --
THAT ARE PICKING UP THE TAB AND
THESE ARE BIG TABS AND THERE'S A
LOT OF RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE.
TO YOU KNOW.
THAT'S OUR JOB HERE IS TO MANAGE
A BUDGET AND MANAGE WHAT AND THE
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO RISE.
AND SO I JUST WANTED YOUR
THOUGHTS AND AS I'M HAVING A
HARD TIME SWALLOWING THIS RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE I KNOW WE STILL HAVE
UNTIL. TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO TWO
IN OF I KNOW YOU GOT A HEAVY
LEFT HERE WITH A TWO THIRDS VOTE
I UNDERSTAND THAT SO I JUST WANT
TO SHARE MY FRUSTRATION WITH YOU.
AND ALSO MY CONCERN ABOUT --
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO DO THE
DAMAGE TO WHO ARE HOWEVER THEY
GOT AWAY WITH IT ARE STILL
GETTING AWAY WITH IT AND I JUST
THINK THAT'S WRONG.
HI EVERYONE AGREES THAT THE THAT
IT'S WRONG IF EVER IT TO ME A
BUNCH OF PEOPLE WOULD BE IN JAIL
RIGHT NOW.
BUT I'M NOT THE QUEEN OF
CALIFORNIA SO I CAN'T MAKE THAT
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT BUT WE'RE
PUSHING FOR THAT THE ME SAY THAT
WHEN WE STARTED WITH THIS BILL
IT ALWAYS INCLUDED THE IDEA OF
THESE LEGACY STATES WE HAVEN'T
HAD IN THAT IT'S BEEN ABOUT A
FIFTH.
DOZEN TO FIT TO FIFTEEN AND AND
IN THE SAME WAY I AM WHOLLY IN
THE ADMINISTRATION ARE TRAVEL
ABOUT BORROWING MONEY FROM THE
FEE AND I'M CALLING THEM OUT.
MAKING SURE THAT WE MADE WHICH
WITH IT'S ABOUT THE LEGACY SITES.
IT'S ABOUT EXCITED THE FACT THAT
WE ALREADY KNOW AND YES IT'S
UNFAIR BUT I HAVE TO WORRY MORE
ABOUT LIKE I HAD I CAN'T GET ON
PEOPLE HOLD ON WAIT GET SICK A
LITTLE BIT LONGER LET ANOTHER
GENERATION.
HAVE THESE ISSUES AS WELL AT THE
END OF THE DAY I FEEL
COMFORTABLE ASKING CONSUMERS TO
GIVE ME ABOUT A DOLLAR EVERY
THREE TO FIVE YEARS WHEN THEY
GET A NEW BATTERY I HAD TO
REPLACE MY CAR BODY.
THAT ARE YOU RECENTLY AND I GOT
TO SEE MY BILL IN INACTION IT
WAS EXCITING.
WE DON'T GET TO DO THAT VERY
OFTEN BUT IT WAS EXAMS LIKE I'M
WILLING TO GIVE THIS DOLLAR TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HELP YOUR
KIDS.
IT'S A MODEL HOPEFULLY I HAVE A
LOT OF OTHER CONTAMINATION MY
COMMUNITY IS A COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN TO LIKE WASTELAND ALL MY
LIFE.
OUT THERE.
BUT YOU KNOW IN IT'S NOT ABOUT
FAIRNESS IT'S ABOUT MAKING SURE
PEOPLE ARE HEALTHY AND LONG TERM
IF WE ARE NOT HELPING THEM GET
HEALTHIER HAVE THESE CLEAN
COMMUNITIES WE'RE GOING TO PAY A
LOT MORE THROUGH OUR HEALTHCARE
COSTS THAT.
IN THE STILL CAN COMMUNITIES ARE
BEING SUBSIDIZED THROUGH OUR
STATE DOLLARS [inaudible]
AND AND NOTHING'S PERFECT I TOOK
A GOOD ENOUGH DEAL BECAUSE I
CAN'T KEEP GOING HOME TO THAT
AND I LIVE IN THAT COMMUNITY AND
AND I ALWAYS JOKE THAT I'D BE A
GENIUS IF I DON'T HAVE ALL THE
CHEMICALS INSIDE OF ME I GREW UP
AROUND --
THANK YOU MISTER DALI FOR
SHOWING YOUR THAT.
YOUR DEDICATION TO THIS ISSUE
AND HOW LONG YOU BEEN ON THIS
COMMITTEE SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
OTHER QUESTIONS REBEKAH.
THANK YOU SOME REMEMBER GARCIA
AT AM I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT
BECAUSE I AGREE WITH YOU THAT
YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO CLEAN UP OUR
SOIL.
FOR OUR CHILDREN ARE COMMUNITIES
AND WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO ALLOW
OUR ENVIRONMENT THREE TOXIC BUT
I WOULD URGE THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE AWAITING A REPORT FROM THE
TSC ITS BEST COME OUT.
THIS MONTH IS THAT RIGHT IN
MARCH YES --
WE HOPE EXACTLY SO THAT'S MY
POINT I THINK WE NEED TO
CONTINUE AFTER THE HEARING THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WE HAD WE
pKNOW THAT DO TSC NEEDS YOU HELD
ACCOUNTABLE AS WE CONTINUE TO
GIVE THEM FUNDS FOR THE CLEAN UP
THAT WE'RE CHARGING THEM WITH.
AND SO I HEARD THAT TO BE A PART
OF THIS PROCESS AS WELL.
YES ABSOLUTELY AND THIS GOES TO
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH MEANS IT'S
GONNA BE.
WHAT SOMETIME IN MAY?
THAT --
THAT'LL BE TAKEN HAPPENED PRO
HAVE THE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
I JUST WANT TO GET IT OUT TODAY
[inaudible]
OTHER QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT SIR --
DO YOU HAVE A CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
RIGHT SO I MERGING AN AYE VOTE --
ONE OTHER THE THE OBJECTIONS WAS
WE'RE NOT EXACTLY SURE HOW MUCH
IT'S REYES --
BUT EVEN AT THE RATE IS COMING
IN EVEN IF IT WERE TO DOUBLE.
AND THEN DOUBLE AGAIN THAT'S I
MEAN IT'S JUST NOT GOING TO BE
ENOUGH.
WE KNOW THAT RIGHT NOW SO AGAIN
WE WILL AND THE TIME IT GOES TO
APPROPRIATIONS HAVE MORE
INFORMATION AND IF.
SOMETHING'S CHANGED RADICALLY WE
CAN FIND OUT BUT IN THE MEAN
TIME AGAIN.
YOU KNOW MAYBE YOU COULD GO FROM
THIRTY MILLION IF YOU HAD
PERFECT ENFORCEMENT.
TO FORTY BUT IT'S JUST NOT GOING
TO BE ENOUGH FOR ALL OF THE
CLEAN UP THAT HAS TO BE DONE SO
THAT'S WHY I'M URGING AN AYE
VOTE SO.
AGAIN -- MY
DOORS OPENED HER DOORS OPEN AND
WE WILL HAVE MORE INFORMATION
BETWEEN NOW AND WHEN --
ARE THE APPROPRIATIONS SAYS HE'S
THE BILL.
ALL RIGHT CAN I HAVE A MOTION.
ALL RIGHT SO MOVED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN SECOND BY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAYOR SU CHI.
AND THE MOTION IS T. PAT TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER ONE AB ONE
FOUR TO ONE FORTY TWO CRISTINA
GARCIA HI THE MOTION IS DO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I MELENDEZ IS ABSENT
ARAMBULA IS ABSENT.
BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DALY.
DALY KNOWN HI CRISTINA GARCIA I
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I MATHIS.
WHAT I TO CHANGE WHAT I TO CHI?
FOR ITEM PRICES OUT FIVE MINUTES
FIVE VOTES IT IS AB
CONGRATULATIONS AND AGAIN --
FOR FOR ALL THOSE INVOLVED WE
WILL CERTAINLY --
BE WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
FUTURE.
ALL RIGHT SO I HAVE TO BILLS
[inaudible]
TO REDUCE [inaudible]
AND I'M GOING TO GIVE THE GAVEL
TO MY GOOD FRIEND --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DOLLY
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
FOUR SOME THE
FIRST BILL A PRESENT ON IS A BE.
FOUR OH TWO AND UP SO.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY
FOR CHERRY AND THANK YOU OTHER
MEMBERS FOR BEING HERE I REALLY
APPRECIATE --
WITH ALL THE OTHER THINGS THAT
YOU DO THAT YOU'RE HERE FOR THIS --
ALSO I WANNA THANK COMMITTEE
STAFF AND A PARTICULARLY --
PAJO VAN CHI OUR NEW ASSEMBLY
SCIENCE FELLOW ARE FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS.
AB -- FOR TO
AUTHORIZES THE STATE WATER BOARD
TO ESTABLISH A FUNDING PROGRAM.
TO SUPPORT LOCAL OVERSIGHT OF
SMALL DRINKING WATER SYSTEMS.
ARE THE PROBLEM WE'RE HAVING IS
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF SMALL
SYSTEMS THAT THIRTY DIFFERENT
COUNTIES.
AND THOSE COUNTIES MAY NOT HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO DO TO
OVERLOOKED THEM.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES.
IS [inaudible]
ARM.
BECAUSE THE COUNTIES DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FEES SIX OF THE COUNTIES
OF ACTUALLY RETURNED DRINKING
WATER OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY BACK
TO THE STATE WATER BOARD.
BOB THE SMALL WATER SYSTEMS THAT
THE STATE WATER BOARD REALLY
DOESN'T WANT TO DO THE OVERSIGHT.
OF WE THINK IT'S THEY THINK IT'S
BETTER DONE AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
BUT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THEY
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY.
SO WHAT THEY DO HAVE IS AN OPT
IN PROGRAM FOR LOCAL AGENCIES.
AND THE GOAL WOULD BE THAT THE
AGENCIES COULD OPT INTO THIS
PROGRAM.
AND THEN THE STATE WATER BOARD
WHICH HAS FEES FROM THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
CAN NÁN HELP FUND THESE LOCAL
AGENCIES.
SO WHAT THIS BILL IS BASICALLY
DOING IS ASKING THE WATER BOARD
WITH THEIR FEES FROM OTHER AREAS.
TO ACTUALLY FUND THE CLEANUP ARE
EXCUSE ME TO FIND THE OVERSIGHT
OF THE SMALL AGENCIES IN THESE
OTHER SMALLER TYPICALLY RURAL
COUNTIES WHICH SIMPLY DON'T HAVE
THE MONEY.
SO WE'RE LOOKING TO HELP THE
SMALL RURAL.
WATER SYSTEMS WITH MONEY FOR
DATE.
THAT'S BASICALLY WHAT THIS IS
FOR I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
ANYONE WOULD NOT OPT IN.
BUT IT IS STILL AN OPTION AND
THEY DO NOT HAVE.
TO I'M HERE TODAY TO JUST TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURES JUST IN MILAN --
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS WHICH IS THE
SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
AND THAT THAT I'LL INTRODUCE THE
OTHER PERSON AND TRY TO KEEP IT
TO A COUPLE OF MINUTES.
MISTER VICE CHAIR WILL COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
JUST ALONG FOR THE LOCAL NUMBER
I'M TO HELP DIRECT AS I WOULD
LIKE TO YIELD MY TIME TO THE
EXPERTS HAVE FROM TWO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BUT TO TEAMED UP
VERY QUICKLY WE BEING A COUPLE
OF YEARS WORKING ON THIS
RESOLUTION.
WOULD NOT TAPPING INTO GENERAL
FUNDS WE NOT TAPPING INTO GRANTS
THE WHOLE IDEA HERE IS RATHER
THAN THE STATE TAKING OVER THE
PROGRAMS WHEN THE LOCALS CANNOT
AFFORD TO DO WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO.
THE STATE WILL SIMPLY USE THE
SAME SOURCE OF FUNDING AND PAY
FOR THE LOCALS WORK WE ALREADY
HAVE A PRESIDENT ESTABLISH IN
THE LOCAL UNDERGROUND TANK
PROGRAM WHICH WHICH IS WORKING
REALLY WELL.
SO THESE NO GENERAL FUND IS
BASICALLY NO NEW FEE ESTABLISHED
WE JUST SORT OF AMORTIZING THE
MONEY MORE EFFICIENTLY FOR THESE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
THOSE THAT WANT TO GIVE UP THE
PROGRAMS WILL HAVE THE OPTION OF
DOING THAT AND I WANTED.
TO INVITE YOLO COUNTY AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY TO EXPLAIN WHY
THIS IS SO IN ITS HISTORY AND
JUST TO EMPHASIZE THAT WE GOT RC
RC AND THE IMAM HEALTH
ASSOCIATION.
AND NINE OTHER JURISDICTIONS IN
SUPPORT WITH NO OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE FOR LETTING
ME SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOUR OH TWO MY NAME IS APRIL
MANY GETTING I'M THE DIRECTOR OF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH FOR THE
COUNTY OF YELLOW.
AS WELL AS THE PRESIDENT ELECT
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
DIRECTORS OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH.
I'M HERE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
AB.
IT'S GONNA PROVIDE A AN OPT IN
LIKE JUST TO MENTION FUNDING
MECHANISM WHICH IS GOING TO HELP
US SECURE --
S. TO SUSTAINABLE FUNDING SOURCE
FOR OUR LOCAL AM PROGRAM PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEM PROGRAM.
WHICH WILL ALLOW US LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO CONTINUE TO
ADMINISTER THE PROGRAM --
AS AS WAS MENTIONED --
THERE THERE'S A LACK OF FUNDING
FOR FOR THIS PROGRAM --
ON THE LOCAL LEVEL WERE NOT ABLE
TO CHARGE THE FEES THAT WE NEED
IN ORDER TO FULLY SUPPORT THE
PROGRAM.
I AM AND THAT IS WHY A MANY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE LOOKED
AT RETURNING THE PROGRAM BACK TO
THE STATE BUT WE FEEL THAT --
IT'S A BETTER PROGRAM TO DO ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL WERE BETTER ABLE
TO SERVE OUR AND OUR PUBLIC AND
OUR CLIENTS SO THANK YOU AND I
URGE YOU.
TO SUPPORT A BEFORE UNTIL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS CHRIS
SUDDENLY AND I'M A REGISTERED
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH SPECIALIST
WITH SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
AND I'M PROVIDING COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB --
FOR TO ON BEHALF OF CCDE. H. --
AS MANY OF YOU ALREADY KNOW AND
AS A SOMEONE AND QUIRK HAS
ALLUDED TO LOCALS ARE. FOR A
VERY LONG PERIOD OF TIME AND WE
ARE VERY GOOD AT BUILDING
CONNECTIONS AND RELATIONSHIPS
WITH.
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY SOME OF
THESE SMALL PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS
TO KIND OF PUT A PICTURE TO IT.
COULD BE YOUR LOCAL CHURCH CAN
BE A SCHOOL --
CAN BE THE NEIGHBORHOOD GROCERY
STORE OR A SMALL RESTAURANT IN
OFTENTIMES THOSE TYPES OF
REGULATED ENTITIES DON'T HAVE
THE YOU KNOW THE REVENUE TO
SUPPORT AND TO PAY.
FOR THESE INCREASINGLY STRINGENT
WATER QUALITY REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE SUBJECT --
TO ON OUR END THE THE WORK THAT
IS NEEDED TO REALLY.
EFFECTIVELY PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT
AND REGULATORY OVERSIGHT WE
DON'T HAVE THE THE MONEY COMING
INTO TO SUPPORT IT.
SO THE THE FORTUNATE THING IS
WITH A BEFORE --
TO DIVE PROBLEM GOES AWAY.
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU KNOW
YOUR SUPPORT TO HELP US CONTINUE
TO DO THE WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
LOCAL IN THE COMMUNITY.
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
OKAY IS THERE --
THOSE WHO WANT TO SPEAK IT
SUPPORT.
YES JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC ONE
OF FIRST THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH US AND YOU HAVE TO THE
LANGUAGE AND JUST SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
AND LANGLEY ON BEHALF OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY ANJELICA NIELSEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THERE ARE THERE THOSE WHO WANT
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
FOR QUESTIONS BY MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GO AHEAD --
YOU KNOW QUESTIONS OKAY WE HAVE
A MOTION FOR THE BILL
[inaudible]
HI.
CRISTINA SECOND BY CHRIS SORRY.
THE CHAIRMAN'S RECOGNITION
RECOMMENDATION IS --
I ON THE IS WITH A STRANGELY
ENOUGH YEAH.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB FOUR
ZERO TWO QUIRK HI THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE.
MELENDEZ IS ABSENT ADAM WAS
ABSENT BAUER QUE HAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DALY.
DALY ENVY NUMBER IN CRISTINA
GARCIA.
RESIDENCIA I HOLDEN HOLDEN I
MATHIS.
WHAT WOULD YOU?
WE HAVE FIVE VOTES AND WINS OUT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT I'M GOING TO SPEAK ON A. B.
FOR THIRTY TWO RIGHT PIECE OF
PAPER.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY AND MEMBERS --
AB FOR THIRTY TWO WOULD CREATE A
STATE VERIFICATION FOR LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS OVERSEEING LOCAL
HAZARDOUS WASTE CLEANUP.
I HAVE AS YOU.
HAZARDOUS WASTE CLEANUP OR SITE
REMEDIATION CAN BE VERY
COMPLICATED.
AND ENVIRONMENTALLY SENSITIVE
DUE TO PROXIMITY TO WATER
SOURCES IN NEARBY COMMUNITIES.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL CERTIFIES.
LOCAL AGENCIES UNDER THE
CERTIFIED UNIFIED PROGRAM. TO
OVERSEE THE CLEAN UP OF
CONTAMINATED SITES.
IF THE TSC DETERMINES THEY ARE
QUALIFIED TO DO SO SO THAT'S
CURRENT LAW IT'S D. T. S. C.
THAT.
DAD DOES THAT TO A BOB
[inaudible]
CERTIFICATION.
CURRENT LAW ALSO AUTHORIZES THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO CERTIFY
LOCAL AGENCIES IS QUALIFIED
CLEANUP.
OR OVERSEE A RESPONSIBLE PARTY
CLEANUP OF SOIL AND GROUNDWATER
CONTAMINATION FROM LEAKING
UNDERGROUND STORAGE TANKS.
IN BOTH CASES THE STATE ENTITIES
INSURE THE LOCAL AGENCIES HAS
THE TECHNICAL EXPERTISE STAFF
RESOURCES AND TOOLS NEEDED TO
OVERSEE OR DO THE SITE CLEANUP.
AB FOUR THIRTY TWO AND THIS IS
NOW OUR IT'S GONNA CHANGE AB FOR
THIRTY TWO EXTENDS THE STATE
OVERSIGHT. TO INCLUDE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS WHO OVERSEE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES CONDUCTING
HAZARDOUS WASTE CLEANUP.
THE INTENT IS CREATE UNIFORMITY
AMONGST THE STATE PROGRAMS.
CERTIFY LOCAL AGENCIES AND
ENSURING COMPLIANCE WITH ALL
APPLICABLE LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
TO MAXIMIZE PROTECTION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION WE HAVE
LOCAL HALL HEALTH OFFICERS
REGARD TO SOME CONCERNS THEY
HAVE RAISED.
UP BASICALLY THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE OVER BURDENED ARMED WITH A
PROGRAM.
WHICH IS --
GOING TO TAKE THEM A LOT OF TIME
OR EFFORT IN WHICH CASE IF THAT
WERE THE CASE THEY WOULD SIMPLY
NOT BOTHER TO TAKE IT.
SO IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THEM
INVOLVED IT'S GOING TO BEHOOVE
US TO COME UP OR DTS SEE AND THE
WATER BOARD. TO COME UP WITH A
TRAINING WHICH IS ADEQUATE BUT
NOT OVERLY BURDENSOME SO THAT'S
THE ENTION
AND WE'RE WE'RE WORKING WITH
THEM CLOSELY AND HOPE TO HAVE
THAT ALL WORKED OUT.
OF BY THE TIME THE BILL IS SEEN
IN APPROPRIATIONS.
NOT.
OKAY I DON'T THINK I HAVE ANY
WITNESSES SORRY.
THE MOTION IS SECOND ON THE BILL
DID YOU HAVE ARE YOU AS BEGIN
SUPPORT.
IN IS -- OF
OR OKAY YEAH SURE.
WITH WOULD LOVE TO TO SEE YOU
WOBBLE.
MISTER VICE IT JUST MELONES THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTORS --
WE WOULD LOVE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL IN FACT.
MY MY BAD WE WE DIDN'T TO
EXPRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS EARLY ENOUGH.
WE REALLY DON'T SEE THE NEED FOR
THE BILL THAT'S THE THING WE
STRUGGLING WITH WE NOT SHOW
WHETHER IT NEEDS A FIX.
SO THAT'S THE PROBLEM THAT WE
BRING TO THE WE HAVE A LOCAL OF
THE SITE PROGRAM WITH STATE
WATER BOARD WE HAVE DTC
OVERSIGHT.
IN THIS CASE THEY HEALTH OFFICES
ARE ALLOWED TO OVERSEE LIMITED
SIDE OVERSIGHT AND THESE
SIGNIFICANT RESTRICTIONS ON WHAT
THEY CAN DO.
WE ALSO IF I HEALTH OFFICE --
ELECTS TO DO THIS OVERSIGHT.
THEY FIRST HAVE TO NOTIFY THE
STATE AGENCY THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO DO IT AND THEY CAN AVAIL
THEMSELVES TO BE.
SORT OF SECOND GUESSED OR NOT
SHUT DOWN IF THE TSC OF THE
STATE AGENCY DOESN'T WISH TO SEE
THAT SITE CLOSE SO THEY ARE
CHECKS AND BALANCES EVEN IN THE
EXISTING PRICES.
SO WE WANT TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR ON THIS BILL BUT
WE DO WANT TO EXPRESS A CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE NOT REALLY HEARD
WHERE THE CURRENT SYSTEM IS
FAILING.
AND AS YOU KNOW WITH THE PRICE
OF LAND IN CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO
CLEAN UP THE SITES THEY'LL
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF SITES
SOME OF WHICH ARE JUST AN OLD
FORTY FOUR GALLON DRUM IN THE
CORNER OF THE LOT.
AND BECAUSE THE THESE AREN'T
BEING CLEANED UP THEY CANNOT BE
USED MORE USE FULLY SO THAT'S
THE CONCERN WE HAVE WE WANT TO
STAY WORKING WITH YOU.
BUT WE DO NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DON'T CREATE NOW THE WHOLE
PROGRAM LAID OVER ON TOP OF THE
HEALTH OFFICES THAT ARE VERY
VERY RESPONSIBLE AND WHAT
THEY'RE DOING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AT JOHN KENNEDY WITH
RC RC OFFER START BY SAYING IT'S
IT'S BEEN GOING TO SAY WHAT ARE
SEE OUR SON OF WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA --
WE'VE APPRECIATED WORKING WITH
YOUR STAFF ON THIS BILL WE'VE
HAD SOME CONSTRUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS ALSO HIT MY COMMENTS
WITH JUSTIN AS WELL ON THE
UNDERLYING NEED FOR THE BILL BUT
WE DO STILL HAVE SOME CONCERNS --
AS YOU SAID IF THE BILL IF THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS BECOMES
AND WHEELED LEE EITHER AND COST
WERE STAFF TIME.
WE PROBABLY WOULDN'T PARTICIPATE
SO WE SHARE THAT CONCERN WE'RE
ALSO CONCERNED WITH APA
EXEMPTION IN HERE AND WITH THE
EPA EXAME PA --
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT --
EXEMPTING THE STATE WATER BOARD
FROM THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT IN THE
CERTIFICATION IN DETERMINING THE
CERTIFICATION STANDARDS.
WE UNDERSTAND THIS PRECEDENT FOR
THAT BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE'RE
NOT SURE THAT THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS WOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE INPUT
INTO WHAT THOSE REQUIREMENTS
WOULD BE --
OR THAT THAT STATE WATER BOARD
WOULD HAVE TO RESPOND OR HOW THE
DUE PROCESS PROTECTIONS WOULD --
PLAY AND FOR DECERTIFICATION OF
A LOCAL OFFICER ALSO HAVE SOME
MECHANICAL CONCERNS ASWELL
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS BETWEEN WHEN
THE BILL GOES INTO EFFECT AND
WHEN CERTIFICATION START SO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOUR
STAFF --
CONTINUE IN THESE DISCUSSIONS
WE'VE HAD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY THUS THE REST OF THE WALLS
I GUESS IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL OR IN
SUPPORT AND I MISS ANYBODY.
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND ON THE BILL ANY
COMMENTS FROM.
MEMBERS NOT JUST IT WILL BE
WORKING VERY.
CLOSELY AND IF I CAN BE
CONVINCED WE DON'T NEED THE BELL.
HEY I DON'T NEED EXTRA BILLS --
I'LL HAVE PLENTY --
BUT WILL IT WILL TRY AND WORK IT
OUT -- I'LL
DEFINITELY --
DO MY BEST TO THE HEALTH
OFFICERS.
AS WELL AS THE DGSE IN THE WATER
BOARD AND JUST TRY TO WORK THIS
OUT AND I PROMISED YOU WILL GET
MY INDEPENDENT JUDGMENT.
THIS IS MY BILL AND YOU KNOW ME.
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS GO AHEAD YEAH SO I
MEAN I THINK THAT WE'VE HEARD
SORT OF THE NEED FOR BALANCE
BETWEEN.
OVERSIGHT ENSURING THE SITES ARE
CLEANED UP PROPERLY AND
EFFECTIVELY AND NOT OVER
BURDENING JURISDICTION SO THAT
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO CLEAN THEM UP --
AND SO I TRUST YOU TO STRIKE
THAT BALANCE I ALSO AM CONCERNED
AFTER SITTING AT THE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
IN HEARING HAD THE TSC CAN'T
COMPLETE THE CURRENTS
JURISDICTION THAT WE'VE GIVEN
THEM GIVING THEM ADDITIONAL
JURISDICTION WITHOUT --
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT NOT THAT I'M
READY GIVE THEM ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT BUT THEY SEEM TO BE
UNABLE.
TO COMPLETE PERMITTING AND OTHER
THINGS WE EXPECT THEM TO YOU NOW
AND WE'RE ADDING ON TO THAT SO I
HAVE CONCERNS.
I EXPECT --
FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD TODAY THAT
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK.
THAT IT OKAY WELL US FOR THE
ROLE.
THIS IS THE AND THIS IS ITEM
NUMBER.
FIVE IT'S AB FOR THIRTY TWO
QUIRK DO PASSED TO ITS --
DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK I MELENDEZ IS
ABSENT -ARAMBULA IS ABSENT
BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN I DALY
[inaudible]
DALY NO.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN HI.
MATHIS.
MATHIS IS NOT VOTING MODE
SWITCHING.
WOULD SWITCHING HI CENTS ONE TWO
THREE FOUR WE HAVE FIVE VOTES ON
THE BILLS OUT BY ONE OF THE
HOUSE THAT I CAN SAY THAT --
THANK YOU --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS WELL LA --
HAVE SOME Mà.
ADD ONS AND THEN I THINK WE'LL
BE DONE.
SO THIS IS TO ADD ON TO ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB ONE FOUR TWO
CRISTINA GARCIA.
WITH A VOTE OF FIVE TO ONE
MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS NO.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB FOUR
ZERO TWO QUIRK THE VOTE STANDS
AT FIVE ZERO MATHIS.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB FOUR ZERO
TWO QUIRK.
NOT VOTING MATHIS IS NOT VERY
THANK YOU.
YEAH I GOT.
OKAY.
AND THEN LIKE I HAD A ON I'M
GONNA DO HERE --
THE BILL [inaudible]
YEAH. ONE WE'RE AND THE CEO OF A
MAN BILL BECAUSE IT'S ON CONSENT
YEAH BUT I WANT TO ASK.
JOINT WITH YOU YEAH SO OKAY SURE
I CAN DO THAT.
YEAH WE WE GONNA MAKE YOU DON'T
DO IT HERE YEAH SO HE WE'VE
ASKED AND WE HAVE A CO AUTHOR
REQUEST FROM MISTER MATHIS
[inaudible]
THE OWNER.
I WOULD YOU LIKE TO JOIN.
THAT'S FINE WILL MAKE YOUR JOIN
AUTHOR.
UP MR MATHIS IF YOU COULD STAY
FOR ONE MINUTE IF YOU HAVE THE
TIME -- SO
I'M GOING TO CLOSE THE MEETING
THE NEXT HEARING WILL BE MARCH.
TWENTY SIX BOB YEAH I DO WANT TO
SAY THAT IF ANY BILL IS
SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED AFTER IT
LEAVES HE COMMITTEE.
I RESERVE THE RIGHT TO BRING IT
BACK -- AND
YES CERTAINLY WITH ALL OF THESE
BILLS WE DO ASK THAT THE AUTHORS --
KEEP IN TOUCH WITH US IF THINGS
CHANGE.
DO I HAVE A MOTION TO THE VERY
TURNED [inaudible]
THANK YOU --